foreign
[Music]
work is the source of all good
walls have ears doors have eyes
[Music]
there is no other happiness but peace
the sweetness of food doesn't last long
but the sweetness of good words does
[Music]
choose one thing that you want to
accomplish don't try to do two difficult
things at the same time
[Music]
slow fires smolder for a long time
to a man wine is like water to a boat he
can carry him or swallow him
[Music]
you have to lose something to get
something
[Music]
wrapped within Rags you might find gold
when the water rises hurry to get some
when the cat is not there the mice are
happy
those who can't dance blame it on the
flute and the drum
worry about things that haven't happened
yet you'll get a headache for nothing
[Music]
friends for a meal are easy to find
friends until the end of life are
difficult to find
thank you
a virtuous person sleeps well
don't eat fruit before it is ripe
it is never too late to mend
[Music]
when there is effort there is success
if you do good good things come to you
if you do bad bad things come to you
if you have bad friends they lead you to
bad if you have good friends they lead
you to good
[Music]
a small bird builds its nest big enough
for itself
[Music]
and lost two Silvers keeping silent
gained one gold
prevention is better than repair
the accent implies your language the
manner implies your clan
nothing is too late to mend
where there is a will there is a way
[Music]
sometimes staying silent is better than
speaking out
don't forget to bring a knife when you
go into the jungle
when you do something take time to do it
carefully
if you live in another person's house
help them
if you want to live together you have to
think of one another
[Music]
if a dog bites you don't bite it back
don't bite the hand that feeds you
you shouldn't spread gossip about people
who are close to you
you know that your friend did a bad
thing but you still helped him you just
found yourself a problem
he who hunts two hairs leaves one and
loses the other
don't cross the bridge until you come to
it
fight or disagree with people who have
more power there's a good chance you're
going to lose
don't be too choosy or else you may end
up with a bad choice in the end
you have to be careful when speaking or
else you may unintentionally advise
someone to do something bad
don't trust the way and don't trust
people if you do you'll get in trouble
that is the way the mouse is cheerful
ten tongues that spread the word are
worth less than two eyes that have seen
and two eyes that have seen are worth
less than one hand that feels
[Music]
the heart of a woman is as capricious as
a drop of water on a Lotus leaf
little is spent with difficulty much
with ease
[Music]
the store of rice in your attic is your
enemy it makes them who have none
jealous
gold that falls to Earth never dims
[Music]
a centipede will not stop for a
don't spoil a cool place under a
hospitable tree
at high tide the fishy dance at low tide
the ants eat fish
bald people can always find a comb
[Music]
a virtuous person sleeps well
you should always prefer wind to water
who is timid in the woods boasts at home
make a good fire with a single stump
love me love my dog
in a town where people wink you must
also wink
[Music]
if you are going into the woods don't
leave your ax at home
don't help the elephant to carry his
tusks
don't borrow someone else's nose to
breathe through
people are the same the world over
they're all deserving of respect
[Music]
never do things by halves
Two's Company Three's a Crowd
forgiving a person who hurts you is a
gift you give him
forgetting a person who hurts you is a
gift you give yourself
[Music]
doing something is better than getting
nothing done
[Music]
living within your means is better than
going into debt to project an image
well done is better than well said
fine feathers make fine Birds the tailor
makes the man
clothes make the man
[Music]
you'll never miss the water till the
well runs dry
[Music]
nothing ventured nothing gained
all are not thieves the dogs bark at
[Music]
do not rely on others outside of
yourself and your family
when a poor man shouts no one listens
but let a rich man merely whisper and
the whole world trembles
[Music]
he who has never aired has never done
anything at all
in love there are no winners or losers
there are only those who are hurt more
or those who are hurt less
nothing is too late to mend
there is but one genuine Love Potion
consideration
look at the face before making a friend
with someone
it's like looking at the cloth itself
before buying the clothes
[Music]
the happiest people are those who give
not those who take
[Music]
one can compete in a boat or raft race
but one cannot compete in the race of
Merit and Destiny
[Music]
please